charles-philippe artur jorge nouveau roi
d'angleterre personne de paris
soit né en 1948 au palais de buckingham
nommé prince de galles en 1969
c'est finalement à 73 ans qu'il accédera
au trône
ça vit ça ce
raisonnement partisans mais aussi à
beaucoup de cérémonies charles a étudié
dans les grandes écoles d'angleterre et
a été pensionnaire en écosse
diplômé de cambridge il a servi dans la
royal air force et dans la marine est ce
quelqu'un qui cultivait qui est bien
c'est que vous voyagez et ce pour
quelqu'un qui dégage beaucoup de
charisme et dans sa serre problème pour
la monarchie en 1981 il épouse en grande
pompe diana spencer
lady die la relation qu'il aura avec
elle n'aidera pas son image
ensemble ils ont deux fils william et
harry
mais ils divorcent quinze ans plus tard
charles admettra une relation extra
conjugale avec camilla parker bowles son
amour de jeunesse
les designers d'un accident de la route
un an plus tard
à la façon dont les médias ont rapporté
sa relation avec
1 56 ans charles épouse camilla en
secondes noces celle qui deviendra
bientôt la reine consort
passionné de botanique d'architecturé
d'écologie le prince charles est aussi
un grand philanthrope qui a créé sa
propre fondation crouch et les causes
qu'il défend vont de l'éducation des
jeunes à la protection des forêts ces
patients c'est notamment pour
l'environnement pourrait jouer un rôle
dans j'irai son discours en tant que
monarque est il le temps qu'il pourrait
donner à son gré
comme prince de galles et les venues de
nombreuses fois au canada sa dernière
visite remonte à mai dernier c'est une
personne très très terre à terre thomas
more un cabana l'a rencontré deux fois
c'est une personne qui aime beaucoup
rencontrer les gens et parler aux gens
nous avons besoin de l'esprit
d'initiative des canadiens c'est un
militaire montréalaise choisi par la
reine qui l'a aidé à perfectionner son
français à l'été de ses onze ans et un
attachement particulier pour le canada
oui mais sa mère a redit une fois je
retourne chez moi au canada puis je
pense que c'est un peu le sentiment qui
est qu'elle partage et à achat le prince
de galles devra maintenant mieux se
faire connaître ici et dans tous les
pays du commonwealth card est moins
populaire que la personne qu'on remplace
c'est toujours difficile surtout qu'à sa
propre mère je pense pas qu'il attendait
cette promotion
de devenir wa jutsu au contrat je pense
qu'il a redouté qu'ils avaient peur de
ce moment fatidique
c'est en deuil que charles commence son
règne il sera proclamé charles iii
vendredi et sera couronné dans six mois
ici jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal